early on the first day of the week while
it was still dark Mary Magdalene came to
the tomb and saw that the stone had been
removed from the tomb so she ran and
went to Simon Peter and the other
disciple the one whom Jesus loved and
said to them they have taken the Lord
out of the tomb and we do not know where
they where they have laid him then Peter
and the other disciple set out and went
toward the tomb the two were running
together but the other disciple outran
Peter and reached the tomb first he bent
down to look in and saw the linen
wrappings lying there but he did not go
in then Simon Peter came following him
and went into the tomb he saw the linen
wrappings lying there and the cloth that
had been on Jesus's head not lying with
the linen wrappings but rolled up in a
place by itself then the other disciple
who reached the tomb first also went in
and he saw and believed
for as yet they did not understand the
scripture that he must rise from the
dead then the disciples returned to
their homes but Mary stood weeping
outside the tomb as she wept she bent
over to look into the tomb and she saw
two angels in white sitting where the
body of Jesus had been lying one at the
head and the other at the feet they said
to her woman why are you weeping she
said to them they have taken away my
Lord and I do not know where they have
laid him when she had said this she
turned around and saw Jesus standing
there but she did not know that it was
Jesus jesus said to her woman why are
you weeping
whom are you looking for supposing him
to be the gardener she said to him sir
if you have carried him away tell me
where you have laid him and I will take
him away jesus said to her Mary she
turned and said to him in Hebrew rabboni
which means teacher jesus said to her do
not hold on to me because I have not yet
ascended to the Father but go to my
brothers and
to them I am ascending to my father and
your father to my god and your God Mary
Magdalene went and announced to the
disciples I have seen the Lord and she
told them that he had said these things
to her when it was evening on that day
the first day of the week and the doors
of the house where the disciples had met
were locked for fear of the Jews Jesus
came and stood among them and said peace
be with you after he said this he showed
them his hands and his side then the
disciples rejoiced when they saw the
Lord
jesus said to them again peace be with
you as the father has sent me so I send
you and when he had said this he
breathed on them and said to them
receive the Holy Spirit if you forgive
the sins of any they are forgiven them
if you retain the sins of any they are
retained
but Thomas who was called the twin one
of the twelve was not with them when
Jesus came so the other disciples told
him we have seen the Lord but he said to
them unless I see the mark of the nails
and his hands and put my finger in the
mark of the nails and my hand in the
side I will not believe a week later his
disciples were again in the house and
Thomas was with them although the doors
were shut Jesus came and stood among
them and said peace be with you
then he said to Thomas put your finger
here and see my hands reach out your
hand and put it in my side do not doubt
but believe Thomas answered him my Lord
and my god jesus said to him have you
believed because you have seen me
blessed are those who have not seen and
yet have come to believe
one of the things we've noticed as we've
read through the Gospel of John is how
much the themes of the early chapters
begin to point us toward the end theme
of glory the theme of being lifted up
the theme of suffering and the theme of
resurrection and Lazarus story and
another thing we've noticed with which
you and I agree which I think we're not
by any means surrounded by all our
colleagues on this one is that John is
partly working with the knowledge of the
synoptic stories that he's I think
deliberately shifting some of our
expectations to to help us understand
the gospel from his own particular
perspective so let's talk about
crucifixion first for a little while how
do we see that as playing on st. Mark's
and Luke's version of the story and yet
enriching it in different ways do you
think yeah each of the Gospel accounts
has a slightly different emphasis when
it comes to the crucifixion of Jesus if
you think about math at mark and Matthew
because at this point at least they're
together who follows Mark's yeah has
Jesus in his final moments crying out my
God my God why have you forsaken me
which can be an understood as a cry of
Darrell absolutely yeah but it's also a
prayer yeah from the Psalms yeah and so
what is it finally is it an expression
of faith or is it an expression of faith
in the depths of despair so there's a
nice ambiguity about it but it shows the
humanity of Jesus oh and then Luke has
somewhat more complicated crucifixion
scene Jesus is a little more serene and
is exemplifying from the cross a value
that Luke takes so there's so much to
heart that is the compassion of God
embodied in Christ you know and so we
have there the story of the Good Thief
right and they sang on the lips of Jesus
Father forgive them for they don't know
what they do textual problem they ought
to work yeah and didn't say yeah it
certainly fits with with what goes on in
Luke's Gospel so in in the Gospel
according to John we don't have any hint
of Jesus being in despair Jesus goes to
his death confident that he's doing the
will of the Father
so that this is one of those points
where the humanity of Jesus does not
shine it's different humanity of
and they say my as it does in the
synoptic Gospels you know at the very
end he sort of serenely says it is it is
completed yeah the work is done so that
ties in the theme Joe John is much more
interested at this point it seems in
tying his themes together then he isn't
trying to give a portrait of Jesus in
his humanity oh I think very much so
very much so the one little detail that
I point out sometimes the students is
that on that little business of whether
Jesus carries the cross or not and and
Mark has simon of cyrene carrying it and
john not only says jesus carried the
cross he basically says he carried it by
himself which i think is one of those
ways of saying over against what you all
expect this man is in charge of this
story and he's going to do just what God
intended him to do without flinching to
the very young right another interesting
feature of course of the passion account
in John is the presence at the foot of
the cross of the mother of Jesus Mary
Magdalene and the Beloved Disciple
and there's that interesting dialogue
between Jesus and those onlookers where
he says to the mother behold yours your
trial
yea panto the Beloved Disciple behold
your mother right and what is going on
there and two ways of reading that one
in terms of hope you will church
politics yeah if you think the Beloved
Disciple stands for some individual in
the history of the johannah community
this in effect bestows on that person a
very high status absolutely so she
becomes Jesus true brother in a way yeah
as opposed to James the other of Jesus
who was playing a very prominent role in
the Christian community of Jerusalem
until he was martyred around what 66 or
more prominent than Peter who apparently
was revered yeah I other groups of
Christians probably in Rome and in
Antioch and we'll see when we come to
the resurrection account a little bit of
I think part of fun is that Peter
beloved disciple thing all the way
through and you Peter's not dead wrong
he's just not quite as good as our boy
that's right so if this if they're there
any points being school then something
like that is probably operative on the
other side there there may be a kind of
symbolic function to this Beloved
Disciple
in this position if he sort of stands
for all of us who are beloved disciples
and I think there is that kind of
exemplary quality to him that is that
he's there on the bosom of Jesus at the
Last Supper so we shoe too should be
he's there when he when the example of
Jesus self giving love is given to the
disciple so we too should be and should
listen and see and he was there with the
cross so we too should be etc so yeah
I'm conserved that exemplary function
and if so he in our stead is put in the
position of a an adoptive brother of
Jesus all would love it and Paul would
love that yes because as he says in
Galatians we cry out God Father showing
therefore that we have four received
adopted sons and heirs he bruised as a
something similar so I think this this
this figure as in so many other cases it
serves a number of functions for drama
and it adds to the complexity thematic
complexity of the passion account now
the themes of the passion that's come to
kind of consummation here what about the
the blood of the water that flow from
inside you often interpreted it
sacramentally that whatever he may do
with the Last Supper here we have
statement about baptism and Eucharist
even though he doesn't come right out
and say here's how you remember me
yeah the the blood and the water from
the side of Jesus on the cross have
sometimes been interpreted in a very
literal physical sense and I've seen a
couple of different attempts to try to
make physiological sense I have two that
if Jesus was dying by a process of
suffocation build up a fluid and they
doesn't preach very well no I've had
other people who have medically trained
people who that kind of whether there's
any historical basis to it I think it
does serve some sort of symbolic
function for John and I think it does
tie in some of the the themes that we
have seen before that is the water that
is a symbol of the insight or knowledge
or revelation that Jesus provides as in
the case of the woman at the web
and maybe even Nicodemus in any case
that comes ultimately from the cross
yeah I think that's Italian and it's not
distinct from the blood that comes from
the cross so that's fair that's right
right whoo right weird weather without
sacramentalism you've got a kind of rich
theological convergence that's right the
one other thing and then I want to see
where you go with the resurrection
stories because I know you've done a lot
of work on those is that is the fact
that the title on the cross is written
in Hebrew and in Greek and in Latin and
I think it goes it goes back to that
what we've been saying all along
however particular John is there's also
that kind of universal claim this is
savior of the world this is king of the
Jews but that's also a word that can be
said to Greek speaking people into Latin
speaking people into Hebrew speaking
people because this is God's love for
the world not only for a particular
people yeah I think that's certainly
right and if you go back to they one of
the first gestures toward a universal
claim for Jesus qua Savior it's back
with the Samaritans absolutely when they
recognized a viewer I think it loops
back around again as in so many other
cases we're picking up stuff that's been
scattered around the gospel so with that
in mind it seems to me one of my puzzles
in reading John is it seems to me in
some ways the gospel writer through
Jesus says when he wants to say about
resurrection in chapter 11 but then
there these stories in chapter 20
because he knows about the appearances
what what what's the function of
resurrection and I hope will ease into
what's the function of the Spirit - and
the in the resurrection church the
church after Jesus died return what's
the way why Mary Magdalene wide Thomas
yeah it's such a rich chapter there's so
much going on in chapter 20 and
resurrection is part of it the life of
the community is part of it the
relationship among disciples as part of
it there are so many things going on and
I think you've you have pointed at a
conundrum in the gospel when you say why
resurrection at all because a lot of the
the symbolism up till now has been
pointing to the cross as the the place
where
we have the true revelation takes place
it's done so why do you need chapter 20
why do you need trap 221 yeah well
actually it's not completed and I think
the the first it's completed but it's
not completed in part because the the
the times over overlap and intersecting
John as they've been doing since yeah at
least chapter 13 maybe even before that
before that in terms of community but in
terms of end time and present time that
that has been a kind of theme running
through from chapter 11 on know so times
are collapsing here but how do they
collapse and and why I think is an
important question alright so if if in
John the cross is at some point the
point where the action the mission of
Jesus is is consummated something must
happen as a result of that right all the
way along we've been seeing that
whatever happens in Jesus has
convocation area for us as individuals
in confrontation with it and for
community that's drawn together behind
Jesus so on the cross the hint of this
is that Jesus gives up his spirit yeah
and that again can be taken of the
simple literal physical readers last
breathe his last right but as in all
other cases where things have a simple
literal physical meaning you can be
pretty sure that it has some other kind
of thing so Jesus breathes his spirit
but where does it go it doesn't have any
impact right so John has in some sort of
narrative way to convey the sense that
yes something significant happens on the
cross that changes the possibilities of
human existence and how does that work
so he tells resurrection stories because
that's how it works
ya know is this a matter of historical
fact that the church was born out of the
residue part of it is just in he just
can't that material is there and it's
telling the story he needs to deal with
him so he deals with in his own rich way
I think and he he yeah it does so in
Spade just think how how the story goes
I mean how many points are scored all
the way along you have the the account
of the race to the tomb Peter and the
Beloved Disciple right right who's gonna
get there first right we'd love a
disciple
he waits a waiter is a deferential to
the not too bright older guy right along
behind him right and the two of them go
in and what happens to them once they're
inside the tomb beloved believes beloved
believes it comes to belief and Peter is
still this crashing yeah yep so without
seeing anything without having any
theological discourse about the
significant signs the palapa disciple
get something yes so maybe not the whole
thing because something and then you
have someone else that you know all
these stories of the resurrection
appearances alike some of the stories of
encounter that we've seen throughout the
gospel people coming to a deeper
appreciation take the Merrimac well I
think Mary Magdalene story is that is
that kind of you've helped me with this
through the years but I think it's her
moving from the necessity of believing
in material physical present Jesus to
how faith goes on in the light of his
resurrection and in that sense departure
that she's not gonna hang on to him
because faith is not going to come that
way anymore but comes to him as the
resurrected one who is both absent and
present yeah there's an interesting line
in there that has been interpreted in
all sorts of ways right Jesus when Mary
has come to recognize who he is
apparently reaches out right and he says
don't be touching that's right yeah and
that's often interpreted as well you're
too unclean you which of course is a
mystery because Mary Magdalene is not a
prostitute right yeah it's certainly not
in job yeah that's another story how she
came to be but in any case what he seems
to be doing is saying don't be hanging
around here exact holding on to me have
a job did exactly you have to go and
tell the decisis American woman in a way
yeah the two first apostles on John are
the Samaritan woman and Mary Megan yeah
which I think sneaks us back to a topic
from earlier that we're not going to
have much time for but I come down on
the side of John as a pro woman gospel
that women have important roles
there's significant witnesses all the
way through yeah I think that's right
although I'm not sure John has totally
discarded somebody male biases
yeah but he certainly gives a prominent
role to several key women no doubt about
that
on the on the spirit we've not had time
in our conversations to talk about the
important role of the Spirit in John's
Gospel very much but but part of the
part of the purpose of resurrection as I
read it is that's the time where Jesus
now actually does hand on the spirit to
the community and in ways I have I've
never been satisfied with my own reading
of how the spirit or the Paraclete works
in John's Gospel but it is clear that
that Jesus departure is not a great
tragedy because this present through the
spirit is as good as having him there
mm-hmm
yeah I think that's right just think
back to chapter 14 in chapter 16 where
he talks about the power clear advocate
yeah at the one whom he will send in his
stead he talks about this spirit almost
in the same breath as he talks about his
indwelling relationship very much so
father and day with the disciples so
it's all part of the same mix having the
Spirit of God is the way in which
resurrection new life relationship with
God all of that happens and through the
activity of the Spirit one gains new
insight the spirit a teacher in John 14
and 16 also a judge and also Jeff so
that for up for us both as the late
first century community and as the 21st
century community the way in which the
story continues to live that that we
drink the water we eat the bread we feel
the judgment we seek the light is
because God's Spirit Paraclete is still
with us doing that for us
mm-hmm and how we move from sight to
faith is also the gift of the Spirit
yeah one way in which I see this tying
together is thinking about that last
episode that that we read here today
where the the Spirit is breathed on the
the disciples in the upper room on
Easter night you know and as the spirit
is breathed jesus Commission's them any
commissions commissioned by
commissioning them in some ways this is
sort of the Pentecost the fourth gospel
where the coming of the Spirit creates a
community as in the beginning of that
allegory much so and the community
that's created by this outpouring of the
Spirit not simply outpouring but in
pouring infusion of the Spirit
is a community that's commissioned to
forgive yeah now they're two there's
also the little double-edged sword whose
sins are forgiven they are forgiven who
sins I retain they are retained right
and what does that mean especially for
those matters that's right that ties us
back in I think to the whole theme of
judgment that has run through the whole
of the gospel and John always has that
as what's her darkness
yeah no trouble yeah so he's not giving
up on that Harvard now whether he
envisions a particular ecclesiological
structure for forgiving and retaining
sins I don't know but he sees the
community as the locus of that Spirit of
God that manifests itself primarily it
seems to me in the forgiveness of sins
and if he's true to his theology of
judgment all the way through it's not
the community who makes the judgment
it's people who make judgment on the
community so the retention is you know
the fact that they have choice not the
community's choice but yeah it's the
creation of the community that does this
D yeah that I think consummates they the
resurrection I think the other place
where where the gospel makes this kind
of moving transition from then to now is
through the Thomas story that Thomas is
there as one who can't believe unless he
sees and Jesus grants him that but it's
clear that for those who come after
including us belief is going to have to
be without seeing and that's not a
disadvantage mm-hmm that's now the
blessing is that we can believe because
of this testimony even though we weren't
there to witness the miracles or to hear
the sermons we are just as much invited
to partake in that story as Thomas or
Peter or even the Beloved Disciple it's
interesting to think about what metaphor
governs the theology of John is it a
metaphor of hearing or medical yeah
sorry or switch do you switch yeah and I
think there is a switch we and we've
talked earlier in our conversations
about some of those passages where
metaphors of sight are so promised yeah
you see the serpent on the Jesus saucer
and lift it out the blind man wounds to
a deeper side but here at the end of the
story after we have all we hope seeing
out the cross we we have Thomas who is
granted the sight but that's not it
that's
site is under conduct and at the same
time we have that Mary Magdalene episode
who comes to know who she is
and know what her relationship to Christ
into God is my ears heard the call he
hears the voice and that of course picks
up another earlier motif the motif of
they the Shepherd on his sheep
yeah his sheep know him by his call they
they hear their names being called so
that that connection is made and it's an
audio connection rather than a visual
connection so it's interesting that
after leading up to this this visionary
experience of John 19 you have to see
the cross with the eyes of faith of
course everything else is is devoted to
the primacy of hearing and you hear a
nice framing device the word has been
spoken at the beginning and at very end
it's the word that makes that we have
here and now the word that was at the
beginning is actually present and
interestingly incarnate not only in the
flesh but in this not in the text I've
got yep here now the word is made flesh
in these chapters mm-hmm that's right
amen